fans singing screaming and filming along
tokio hotel on their 2015 world tour are
as popular as ever
their latest album is called kings of
suburbia
yeah come bail yeah a lot of Quebec ssin
and then we grew up and went to school
it's a way of life when the four of us
are together we feel great crack jokes
all day long have this amazing energy
it's a feeling that stays with you same
was when I was a boy on my bike the
twins Tom and Bill cowlitz grew up in
Letcher about 10 kilometers north of
magdeburg in eastern Germany it was the
1990s shortly after reunification and
the region was one of the most
economically depressed in the country
music was a way of counteracting boredom
in 2001 they teamed up with two friends
to found the van devilish
pretty soon the music prodigies were a
local hit they put on shows for a
handful of friends and family and even
an interview or two two years later a
talent scout brought them to the music
hub of Hamburg devilish was then renamed
tokio hotel and the very first single
was a hit
and I
I
for Bill miss my bus and woke up in the
very beginning bill and I knew we wanted
to make music so we started early mornin
was among even though they sang in
German the boy band developed a huge
international following first in Europe
then in the US and latin america tokio
hotel went on to become a global
sensation and won a string of awards the
four teens grew up in the limelight but
they paid the price especially the twins
in the tabloids rumors and suspected
scandals were constantly making
headlines Amy's commands Angus noise as
similans ninety-five percent of what you
read in the papers is all wrong there's
a tiny grain of truth about ninety-five
percent of what they write is pure
invention I was good after that as a
fire full management inc a lot of times
I think why do people who say they like
us have to write stuff like this they
should just find someone else bushman
amends does that condition
but meanwhile they're all grown up and
they don't shy away from courting
publicity tokio hotel a global
phenomenon that got its start in a small
town in eastern Germany
you